[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Hello.
My name is Natalie
Villalobos, and I'm so
excited today to bring out
Amy Schumer and Aidy Bryant.
They are two incredible
women that I am so incredibly
inspired by and empowered by.
So let's go ahead and
bring them on out.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
AMY SCHUMER: The Google plants.
Hi, guys.
AIDY BRYANT: Oh, cool.
A music room.
AMY SCHUMER: This will be fun.
This is where the
Counting Crows counted.
Thank you for having us, guys.
[CHEERS]
Blessed.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: All right.
So to kick us off, you two
are in a new film together
called "I Feel Pretty."
Tell us what interested you
in signing on to this project.
AMY SCHUMER: Money, honey.
Money, money, money, money.
I don't care.
Money.
AIDY BRYANT: Wow.
AMY SCHUMER: Oh, you guys
hate money at Google?
I'm sorry.
Ker-ching, ker-ching,
ker-ching, ker-ching, ker-ching.
No, I was supposed to do this
other movie where I would've
gotten like a lot a
lot a lot of money,
but it wasn't going
to really work out
because-- but this is the exact
message that I've been wanting
to say, like I didn't want this
to just be part of the movie.
I was like, I really want to
hammer this exact message home.
And so I'm kind
of like a [BLEEP]
when it comes to if my
manager sends me a script,
I'll go do you
want me to do this?
Do you want me to
play a reindeer?
You know, and--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Has that happened?
AMY SCHUMER: Like ish.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
AMY SCHUMER: And so
they were like, hey, we
think this is worth mentioning.
And they told me the premise,
and I was like that's awesome.
And then I read the script.
I was like, this is so funny.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: She's
giving you lovey eyes.
AMY SCHUMER: I know.
She wants it.
Are you lower?
AIDY BRYANT: I'm just
feeling like I'm lower.
AMY SCHUMER: You're lower.
Well, we just had this.
AIDY BRYANT: I'm sorry.
AMY SCHUMER: Why am I so high?
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
You're in the middle.
AMY SCHUMER: We did one
this morning at either,
like one of you, and--
AIDY BRYANT: And we got there,
and they kept saying to me
like, Aidy, you'll be
in the middle chair.
OK, just remember, Aidy,
go in the middle chair.
AMY SCHUMER: And you're
in the middle chair.
AIDY BRYANT: Go to
the middle chair.
AMY SCHUMER: Because
at these things,
they really over-explain.
AIDY BRYANT: And I'm like, OK.
AMY SCHUMER: They're like
breathe, and you'll sit
and you bend your knees to sit.
AIDY BRYANT: OK.
And then we got out
there, and we sat down
and mine was like
a little toadstool.
AMY SCHUMER: Yeah.
It was like--
AIDY BRYANT: I was literally
on the ground like in a basket.
And Amy and the moderator
were like seated high.
It was very humbling.
And I'm proud to be lower now.
AMY SCHUMER: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
If you want, we
could switch roles
at some point,
and you can be the moderator.
AMY SCHUMER:
There's nothing that
could get me to get into
one of these seats again.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
Sorry about that.
That's why I'm like kind
of doing the one leg off.
AMY SCHUMER: No, this is great.
AIDY BRYANT: I'm
so scared that I'm
going to show my full coochie--
AMY SCHUMER: Yeah.
AIDY BRYANT: --to
like all y'all.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So
we'll just strategically
place the plants.
AMY SCHUMER: Yeah.
AIDY BRYANT: I'm going to hold
one of those little plants
right here.
AMY SCHUMER: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So with the film,
did you have any creative
control over your characters?
Sounds like the
script was there,
you signed on, and at
any point did you ad lib
or change the original
direction of a character?
AMY SCHUMER: You're naughty.
Yeah.
I'm a producer of this
movie, and it's cool.
I've gotten myself into a
position where I don't have
to say [BLEEP] I don't want to.
And so I helped rewrite it, and
we were super collaborative.
Yeah, and we ad
libbed a little bit.
AIDY BRYANT: Yeah.
Unfortunately, I only had to
say things I didn't want to.
This was a bad experience for
me, and it sucks to be here.
AMY SCHUMER: I'm sorry.
And I know we're all supposed
to be like lifting up
other women in this business.
But I just wanted
to push her down.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So you
wrote it into her contract
to only give her bad lines.
AMY SCHUMER: Yeah.
AIDY BRYANT: No, we
improvised a lot.
AMY SCHUMER: Because we always--
we have like one brain.
Like all the time we'll
always say the same words.
AIDY BRYANT: Same words.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So in the film-- so
I got a chance to sneak peek
watch it on Friday night,
and it was awesome.
AMY SCHUMER: Thank you.
Yeah, it's like hold
for a compliment.
People are like, I saw the show
this week, and then you go mmm?
AIDY BRYANT: And?
AMY SCHUMER: Do, do,
do, do, do, you know.
OK.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
No, I really loved it.
So one of my favorite
parts was actually
when your character, Renee,
was taking some web traffic
reports to her company.
There was a mantra.
She had to say I am brave,
I am blond, and I got this.
AMY SCHUMER: Mm-hm.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So
what body-positive mantra
would you give to
women of the world?
AMY SCHUMER: OK.
Well, first of all,
Adrian Martinez,
who I've worked with a bunch,
he improvised that line.
And he just kind of went nuts
and was giving me his pep talk.
And it made it into the movie.
So God bless him.
Don't be fooled by the
illusion of equality
we've all been sold.
AIDY BRYANT: And yeah.
AMY SCHUMER: I don't
have to tell you, Google.
AIDY BRYANT: That's why
she's on a high stool.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
That was perfect.
AMY SCHUMER: I mean, we
gotta still work for it.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: She did
not hear this question at all.
AMY SCHUMER: They're
like, yeah, well
we weren't impressed
with what she said.
So that makes sense.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
How about you?
AMY SCHUMER: Yeah, what's
your mantra, bitch?
AIDY BRYANT: Currently, it's
like just stay on the stool.
[LAUGHTER]
Just use the chair.
You can grab onto Amy.
Just--
AMY SCHUMER: Oh, OK.
AIDY BRYANT: --stay
on the stool.
AMY SCHUMER: Honey.
Honey.
AIDY BRYANT: I'm
in a bad situation.
AMY SCHUMER: We
had an interview--
AIDY BRYANT: And I'm
legitimately scared.
AMY SCHUMER: We had an
interview this morning
kind of with a
question like that,
where they were like,
I'm not afraid so I--
and like, you know,
it was looking for us
to say something inspirational.
And Aidy was just like,
I'm scared of birds.
And we're like, no that's not--
AIDY BRYANT: I am though.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I'm
scared of deviled eggs.
AMY SCHUMER: Eh.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Yeah, I know.
AMY SCHUMER: I'm scared
of crazy bitches.
You guys.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Deviled eggs, birds.
AMY SCHUMER: They're so good.
I almost just got
those at lunch.
AIDY BRYANT: OK, I'm now--
I'm going to try something else.
AMY SCHUMER: Lean in.
AIDY BRYANT: No,
that's Facebook.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: It's OK.
AMY SCHUMER: It is?
AIDY BRYANT: OK.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So speaking
of leaning in a little bit,
I feel like there's some
shamelessness in the movie.
What would you say
in one word, what is
that confidence that she had?
AMY SCHUMER: Like, you know,
we got this backlash which
was really funny, because
first of all, very flattering.
People were like, you're
not disgusting enough
to be in that.
And I was like, oh.
Am I supposed to--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: What,
she said not disgusting--
AMY SCHUMER: No.
Yeah, they were like,
you don't have any right
to feel bad about yourself.
And it's not a story of a
very homely, awful woman
who finds confidence.
It's just somebody who
struggles with self-esteem,
which everyone does, you know?
And she feels very invisible
and then goes through
this whole experience
where she realizes
where your confidence
really should come from
and what's actually sustainable,
which is not your looks.
So we got this crazy backlash,
and it was funny, you know?
I don't remember.
I don't remember like at
all what I'm talking about.
AIDY BRYANT: No.
I was just thinking too, like
I was also getting messages
that were like, come on.
How could they have Amy Schumer
do this role when they have
a plus-sized woman right there?
She could have done the role.
And it's like, OK.
So you're saying
I'm out of the norm
enough that I should
play the troll
or like what are we
fighting about this for?
I feel like it really
muddles the issue that
is like, you know, Amy and
I both, whether you like it
or not, are not the norm
in movies, you know?
Like 99% of movies, nobody looks
like me or Amy, and we [BLEEP]
good.
AMY SCHUMER: Yes, we do queen.
Say yes, queen.
AIDY BRYANT: No but--
I guess, to me, it's
almost like a snake
eating its own tail where
it's like, well, how--
what do I have to
be or what does Amy
have to be to like--
this is a story that
is about self-confidence, which
truly is like it's all in here.
It's not out here.
And that is what
it's all damn about.
AMY SCHUMER: It's
all damn about,
and we have talked about
this, where we both feel good
in our skin and--
AIDY BRYANT: On
the stool [BLEEP]..
AMY SCHUMER: I mean, this
is a special scenario.
AIDY BRYANT: It's literally
bringing me back down
to like I'm 13 years old.
AMY SCHUMER: Yeah.
No.
This is a bad moment for you.
This is your bottom.
But we realized like
you really-- it's
not about us feeling
good about ourselves.
It's like we have
to literally comfort
other people about our bodies.
They're like, so you just go
out to the store in the morning
and you're just in your
body, and you're like yeah,
and I'm happy.
And they're like, can
you walk me through that?
And you're like, no,
I don't think I can.
So it's literally us
explaining to other people,
making them comfortable.
But you know, there's
nothing scarier
or more upsetting to
people than a woman who
feels good about herself.
People really hate that.
Yeah.
So they're like,
OK, well how can I
find an angle where
you're unhappy so I
can sleep at night?
And you're like,
yeah, of course.
Like we have struggles
like everyone else.
And also, we want to say if I
were a person of color hearing
this conversation, I'd be
like is it hard for you guys?
You know?
And I hear you.
And we both really
want to do our part
and make sure that our work is
super inclusive and not just
for people of color
but trans people,
people with disabilities.
You know, because
what we're learning
is that the leaders being
all white men for so long
is not actually that great for
everybody, and we need women.
If you think about it, women
aren't even on many boards.
Like to get like
one woman, two women
in there-- and by the way,
you have to see the Ruth Bader
Ginsburg movie.
Can we just [MUMBLING].
But you know, it's-- because the
things I gravitate toward are
women.
People are getting-- so
if I was the person making
the decisions-- and Samantha
Bee did that awesome piece
this week about how 1 in 10
women have endometriosis,
but there's very
little research,
but there's like
1,000 dick pills.
You know?
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: No, I've
actually recently started
telling people in my meetings
when I'm having intense cramps.
So it's like I'm just going
to be very real with the fact
that I'm just like in pain.
AMY SCHUMER: Yeah.
I'm--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I'm not
going to hide that anymore.
AMY SCHUMER: No.
I know.
But we do.
AIDY BRYANT: And
[BLEEP] got a problem.
Deal with it.
AMY SCHUMER: Whoa.
AIDY BRYANT: That's
what I'm saying.
I love that.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
[INAUDIBLE] this time.
Yeah.
That's exactly what I said.
AIDY BRYANT: And I do
have a problem right now.
AMY SCHUMER: Yeah, you do.
You're in it.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So you had mentioned--
we can sit with it
a little bit more.
AIDY BRYANT: I'm
tempted to just stand.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: You can--
this will be like--
AMY SCHUMER: Yes, girl.
AIDY BRYANT: I can't tell you
the relief I feel right now.
And so I--
AMY SCHUMER: I'm still
up here like an asshole.
AIDY BRYANT: No, no, no.
Look.
I'm going to just stand in
the spot where my stool was.
AMY SCHUMER: Just stand.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So--
AIDY BRYANT: I'm going to.
I'm sorry.
AMY SCHUMER: Do it.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
We can all stand.
AIDY BRYANT: No, no.
AMY SCHUMER: No.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So when I was 14,
my mom would tell me,
oh, Natalie, don't worry.
Your boobs will grow in,
which I'm still waiting for.
But you know, I used
to wear a water bra,
and so it was like a
bra-- for those of you
that don't know-- water
bra is a bra with two
big sacks of water.
And it basically made me go
from like a double A to a C.
And I would walk around really
confidently as a sophomore.
And I was really
just like moved.
I was like, OK, so I have to
change how I present myself
based on how my mom or how
other women perceive me.
And so I'm curious, how have
other people's perceptions
shaped who you are today
or perceptions of yourself?
AMY SCHUMER: Well,
first of all, thank you
for trusting us with
the water bra story.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
Yeah.
You're welcome.
AMY SCHUMER: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: It
was a vulnerable moment.
AMY SCHUMER: No, totally.
I mean, I used to wear like very
padded bras, like to a point
where it was just like it was--
somebody should have just sued
me when they hooked up with me.
Like, this is not--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
That's where I was headed.
AMY SCHUMER: --at all what
I entered the contract for.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I got--
I got-- yeah.
AMY SCHUMER: But
you know, that--
but that company got to your
mom, and they like, you know,
all the marketing and you've got
to look like this one person.
And if you cover all
the heads in the gossip
magazines across the row,
everyone has the same body.
And you're told if you don't
look like this one thing,
then you're wrong.
And then you realize like, no.
And what is it about?
It really is about how
you feel about yourself.
And we know that.
That's easy to say.
But the way that you want your
friends to see themselves,
like your best friends,
who are like, meh.
And you're like,
you're so pretty.
[BLEEP] you know.
Sometimes you can cover
their head in a picture
and be like, what if you
saw this girl walk by?
Wouldn't you be like,
that's a beautiful girl?
And they're like, oh, yeah.
But I think other
than the media,
it's like I think mothers need
to know how much their message
goes through to their kids.
Yeah, because if they're
going, oh, I'm disgusting.
Like their daughter is
going to be like, I'm gross.
My mom did the
opposite and just made
me think I was actually
Beyonce as a child.
And then you know, you get
older and like stuff chips away
at your confidence,
and kids are mean,
and you kind of
are like, oh, OK.
Oh, I'm gross.
I'm disgusting.
OK.
And this movie is about
trying to get back
to that childlike version of
yourself where you feel good,
and you're not thinking
you need a water bra.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
Well, and I think
part of the sisterhood
that you were able to
offer her in the movie
was like group
friendship, right,
and supporting someone,
both through the good
and the bad of their body
image and those perceptions.
So can you tell me a little bit
about how important sisterhood
is as we kind of
look at ourselves
and reflect on ourselves?
AMY SCHUMER: Tell her
about our traveling pants.
AIDY BRYANT: Oh.
No, I mean, honestly for me--
and this is maybe going to
sound corny, but like for me,
my friends and my
female colleagues
who have encouraged me have
been my only way to success.
At least for myself, and like I
was so encouraged by performers
who I admired early on in
Chicago or wherever were like,
I would have never
continued going
without their encouragement.
And even like now,
I'm navigating
this whole other
thing, which is how
do I exist as a fat
woman on TV that's
not a mom character who's
in her 40s, like whatever.
You know, that is like
that's where people
are comfortable
seeing my body type,
but I got hired to
"SNL" when I was 24.
So those aren't--
those are like--
so I'm trying to find my
own place in this system
where there hasn't really been
a place for me previously.
And I could not do it
without people like Amy
or my friends who are
encouraging me and helping
me navigate all the
fricking bull [BLEEP]..
AMY SCHUMER: Which is funny,
because people look like us
all over the country.
Like we're the norm.
AIDY BRYANT: Actually, everyone
in the world looks like me.
AMY SCHUMER: Yes.
Yes.
AIDY BRYANT: Like
70% of American women
actually have my body type.
AMY SCHUMER: Right.
AIDY BRYANT: But they're
not reflected on screen,
and that's just
not [BLEEP] fair.
AMY SCHUMER: And we're
not skinny shaming either,
like everybody feels like
[BLEEP] if you're a woman--
and not that men don't feel like
insecure, especially this time.
You're like, what's our place?
Like, can we go to
a Times Up meeting?
And you're like, oh, you
guys all hate us now?
But it's not about--
I mean, yes, like yes.
And thank you, but--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
What's the weirdest thing
you've done for beauty?
AMY SCHUMER: For
most of my life,
like wore heels and those
kind of bras and Spanx
and still felt really mediocre.
That's the weirdest
thing I did for beauty.
Just like my whole
life, every day, until
like pretty recently.
The guys in here look like
the guys in the movie,
like that's my romantic lead.
So you guys will like this.
You guys are definitely
the sweet, like--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Intelligent.
AMY SCHUMER: You
don't look like--
well, you know, don't
put words in my mouth.
But um-- it's like a
very gentle, gentle man.
AIDY BRYANT: I'm trying to--
I don't know if I have
like a weirdest thing I've
done for beauty.
I don't know.
I feel just like buying
jeans, I'm like that's a hell,
and every time I do it, I'm
like, what is happening?
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Last question
before we jump to Q&A, when
that voice inside yourself
says you can't do it, what
do you say to that voice?
AMY SCHUMER: I think
personally I learned along--
I learned like
maybe 10 years ago,
I don't even have
that voice anymore.
I'm like, it's other people
telling you you can't do it.
And you just go like,
I'm going to do it.
You know?
I mean, seriously.
It's like, no.
I'm not giving energy
to any of that.
Just like, no, I'm going to take
the steps I need to to do it.
AIDY BRYANT: I definitely
still have that voice.
But I also feel now like I
have always been like very bad
at rules or if someone tells
me I have to do something,
I immediately am like, I
guess I'm [BLEEP] not doing
that [BLEEP],, which
includes this stool.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
You could not have
done that on a stool.
AIDY BRYANT: No, like--
AUDIENCE: Do you want a--
AIDY BRYANT: No, I don't.
AMY SCHUMER: It's
too late in the game.
AIDY BRYANT: It's done.
Thank you.
This is so nice.
AMY SCHUMER: That's nice.
AIDY BRYANT: Oh, that's OK.
AMY SCHUMER: Oh, cool.
A man is saving you.
Just kidding.
Isn't that funny?
We're still like, can
you open my car door?
Thank you.
AIDY BRYANT: No,
that was very nice.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
You can just hold it.
AIDY BRYANT: I will.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
AMY SCHUMER: I hope they bring
out three more chairs for you
to just--
AIDY BRYANT: They put
me in a little box.
AMY SCHUMER: Yeah.
Just go in your little sandbox.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So I think
we're going to go to Q&A.
AMY SCHUMER: Great.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
First question.
AUDIENCE: Hello, ladies.
I'm very happy you're here.
And I absolutely love your
honest raunchy feminism.
I have an 8-year-old
daughter, who
got invited to her
first dress-up party,
where they're going to
give her makeup and hair.
She has to wear a dress and get
in a long pink stretch limo.
I'm a hardcore feminist.
My daughter knows this.
I look like this.
How do I wrap my
head around that?
What advice can I give her
so she still knows she's her
but can go because all
the other girls are going?
AMY SCHUMER: It's
a great question.
Well, I would assume
mothers love getting advice
from people without
children about how
to raise their daughters.
My instincts, as someone
who's been fiercely
on birth control for a long
time, if she likes that stuff,
then cool.
But if it's not her jam, like--
[SNEEZE]
bless you-- then like peace out.
AIDY BRYANT: Totally.
I mean, I keep thinking like--
I don't know.
I feel like, especially
for what we do,
we have to get
dressed and cinched
and painted up all the time.
And there is like a part of
it that's like [BLEEP] guys
show up 10 minutes
before and they whatever.
But like, you know, there's
also like a part of that
that's self-expression
that I think,
at least for me back
in my childhood--
AMY SCHUMER: We like
our outfits today.
AIDY BRYANT: --like it was
fun to learn about that stuff
and see how I wanted to be.
So I think there's
like, you know,
there's good in a
little bit of all of it
but in moderation, right?
AMY SCHUMER: And don't
get the limo, though.
AIDY BRYANT: No.
But honestly, could we come?
AUDIENCE: They got the limo.
It's Noe Valley.
They got the limo.
AIDY BRYANT: Where and kind of--
AMY SCHUMER: What corner, like--
AIDY BRYANT: Do they
have room for two more?
AMY SCHUMER: Yeah, I don't know.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Thank you.
AMY SCHUMER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So first of all,
you both are beautiful.
Aidy, I love your
short squeeze video.
I remember the first time
I saw that, I was like, yo,
this girl's got to be in
"SNL," and then you were.
So holy [BLEEP].
AIDY BRYANT: I have to tell
you-- can I just tell you
briefly that that video was
something I was paid to do.
It was an advertisement.
And I believe I was paid $25.
AUDIENCE: My question
is, so my younger sister
is trying to be a stand-up
comedian in Chicago.
She's actually sort
of trying to follow
in both of your footsteps.
She's a huge fan
of both of yours.
I'm not that funny.
So I don't really have
any advice to give her.
But every time she
calls me on the phone,
she's giving me this whole
thing about how hard it
is to be a woman in comedy.
And you know, I was shocked when
I saw on "Saturday Night Live"
too that Tiffany
Haddish was, I think,
the first female
stand-up comic--
or black female stand-up
comic-- ever to host the show.
And I was like,
it's [BLEEP] 2018.
What the hell is happening?
So what is it going
to take to get comedy
to a place of more gender
and race diversity?
You know, just like
a small question.
AMY SCHUMER: Well, first of
all, for her, just any comedian
I say just get as much
stage time as possible.
AIDY BRYANT: Same.
AMY SCHUMER: And in terms of
it being harder for a woman,
I just think it's
harder for a woman
to leave the house
in the morning,
like it's just all harder.
And I think, you know,
"Saturday Night Live"
is an example of a very
fun, great show that
is run by white men.
And so that's why
we need more leaders
to look all different to make
sure that things like that
are more diverse.
And there's more equal
number of sort of female or--
people of color, like--
honestly, whatever it is.
And that's me.
AIDY BRYANT: And I
guess I would just
say that I also think like
when those moments come along
when like, you know, Tiffany
Haddish is hosting "SNL" to be
like calling it out.
I mean, like damn,
this is the first time
a black female stand-up
has ever hosted the show.
Something to think about.
I feel like for a
long time nobody
was talking about it openly,
and I think that's part of--
oh, I'm sorry.
I just--
AMY SCHUMER: Oh.
I'm so sorry.
AIDY BRYANT: No.
It's OK.
AMY SCHUMER: I fell asleep.
AIDY BRYANT: Oh.
Oh.
AMY SCHUMER: Time's up.
No.
Thank you for calling that out.
AIDY BRYANT: Yes.
AMY SCHUMER: Don't
be afraid to--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So to
add to that a little bit,
so it's like you have
people who are on stage
but also writers too, right?
We need more women
writers, people of color
who are writing.
It's like the other roles
too that might not be visible
but that are critical.
AIDY BRYANT: And
I also think a lot
of that is on some of these
comedy clubs and stand-up
places and like the theaters
in Chicago where you learn
and start to do that.
It's like they need to be
reaching out and getting
these people in positions where
they can also be seen by people
who are coming to scout.
So it's sort of like--
it's like everybody
should be putting in the work.
You know?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm in a comedy sketch group,
all Asian-American women
here in town.
So I wanted to ask about your
sketch-writing process, when
you have an idea,
then how do you
get it to a tight place where,
you know, I got this winner?
AIDY BRYANT: Well, you had
a full sketch show that
won Peabody's and is a thing.
Don't look at me.
AMY SCHUMER: It's
not about that Emmy.
[LAUGHTER]
No.
She's asking you.
You are currently in
the sketch universe.
AIDY BRYANT: Gosh,
tough question.
I think it's also like
different for every person.
And there's different ways.
For me, at "SNL," I
try to just like really
go off of what is on
my mind that week,
because we really do only
start writing on Tuesday,
and the show is on Saturday.
So you know, the
turnaround is quick.
And if you have something that
you're kind of just like slowly
dumping out, it's going to
be a really long, hard week,
you know?
Like you kind of have
to have something
that you're a little
bit passionate about
and feels either fun
or topical or whatever
that feels important to you.
And then-- because
the whole week
is a little bit of a battle to
try and keep it in the show.
So you want to feel like,
oh, I believe in this.
And then as far as getting
it tight, I think, to me,
it's just like listening to
audiences and being like,
wow, I really love
this part in the middle
but it played to dead silence.
And so we're going
to cut it out.
And even though it makes our
sketch that was five minutes,
now it's three minutes
and 30 seconds,
it's better for it,
because it has more impact
and it's tighter.
So you know?
AMY SCHUMER: The
audience lets you know.
Like, we tested--
you test the movie,
and you're like, OK, my
favorite joke coming up.
And the audience is just like--
[LAUGHTER]
--and you can't be
like, no, you're wrong.
Like, let me just get
up and really quickly
explain why that's funny to you.
Like you have to pay
attention to that and edit.
AIDY BRYANT: Yeah.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AMY SCHUMER: What's
your group called?
AUDIENCE: Granny Cart Gangstas.
[CHEERS]
AUDIENCE: So in the movie,
your character hits her head
and gains all this
self-confidence.
Given that most of us aren't
going to get to hit our heads
and get that self-confidence,
is there anything
that you would suggest as like
a real-world way to get that?
AMY SCHUMER: Well,
see, this movie--
yeah.
Like it just-- it takes--
it's been a process, you know?
It's these little
false starts are like,
I feel good about myself,
maybe forever now.
And then, you
know, again-- woo--
and you eh.
That was me getting my period.
And I know you guys aren't
allowed to get that at Google.
They're like little gymnasts.
But I think paying attention
to when you feel the best.
And it's like when
you're with your friends,
you're just laughing
and you're not
thinking about
what you look like,
and that's when you're happy.
When you're not looking in the
mirror and you're not fixating,
it's like you find
what you really
get your confidence from.
And then just hanging onto that
and just reminding yourself,
I feel good right now.
I'm going to remind myself when
I don't that, first of all,
I will feel good
again, and this is just
a feeling I have
right now, and it'll
be replaced by another feeling.
Yeah.
Hashtag yeah.
AIDY BRYANT: No, I agree.
I feel like, at least for me,
like so often what I go back to
is like what is my value?
And it's not my body.
It's like my comedy, my writing,
my mind, my performance,
my timing, like
all those things.
And it's easy to
stop hating yourself
when you start going
through your list of,
wait, why am I
valuable to this world?
And you know, I don't think it's
because of my thigh, you know?
Like I never have, really.
And so even though the world
is telling you like your thigh
matters, it kind
of [BLEEP] doesn't.
So once you can start to think
about that, it is easier.
Do you guys want
to see my thigh?
AMY SCHUMER: No.
Leave them alone.
AIDY BRYANT: Oh, you
already did actually.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Thank you.
I wanted to end on
a quote I actually
saw on Twitter to wrap us up.
AMY SCHUMER: You
guys are fat whores.
AIDY BRYANT: I'm a fat bitch.
[LAUGHTER]
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
It is not that at all.
AIDY BRYANT: Those are the main
quote we've seen on Twitter.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: This is that
one mind thing happening again.
No.
AMY SCHUMER: Jump off
the bridge, ya hogs.
AIDY BRYANT: I'm sorry.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: No.
No, don't worry about it.
I was actually going
to say something
like some days you eat
salads and go to the gym,
and some days you eat
cupcakes and refuse
to put on your pants.
And it's called balance.
AMY SCHUMER: I like
the hogs bridge one.
Thank you so much, guys.
AIDY BRYANT: Thank you.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Thank
you so much, Amy and Aidy.
[APPLAUSE]